meters down from here we know the areas
we're searching there's no need for us
to be in a big group like this so red
wine to get a new route first gives us a
couple of minutes Head Start we'll get
clear we'll go straight to our sector
and work from there the international
search and rescue team from Britain are
a much needed site for the locals here
they've been on the ground for less than
half an hour and they are already
getting stuck in within minutes of their
arrival people were rushing up to them
begging for them to search in their area
their particular apartment where they
believe their relatives are they will be
here for some time and having spoken to
them earlier a couple of them earlier
they insisted that they're here to save
lives and they do not think it is too
late